[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir verbringen im durchschnitt eine
stunde täglich mit kochen in jüngster
zeit erleben wir eine koch money mit
weltweit erfolgreichen reality tv shows
sowie koch hersteller in sozialen
netzwerken
kochen ist allgegenwärtig sieht sich
aber auch mit den herausforderungen von
morgen konfrontiert
[Musik]
kochen hat viel mit ökologie es ist
nichts wissen von einer elite
entschieden aus globalen
wirtschaftlichen gründen werden wir alle
unser konsumverhalten verändern das
kochen muss eigene lösungen für die
zukunft finden
veganer bewegungen lokale
erzeugergemeinschaften unterstützt von
chefköchen und verbrauchern die sich
zunehmend für die herkunft ihrer
lebensmittel interessieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]